you
[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
to my talk my name is Alison and I hope
some of you were lured in by the title
of this talk because there was a part of
me that had a strange sense of
satisfaction bringing a Britney Spears
song into a data engineering talk but
I'm actually not really going to talk
too much about Britney today I'm mostly
going to be talking about the work that
we at cortico which is a nonprofit out
of the MIT Media Lab have been doing to
identify duplicate content in talk radio
alright so I'm going to start by going
over our problem why we're even looking
at this then talking about a solution
the existing tools out there and then go
more in depth about our solution both in
an algorithm perspective as well as an
infrastructure perspective because it
turns out we needed to throw quite a few
machines at this problem and finally
shows some hopefully nice-looking
results all right so you might be
thinking wait talk-radio that that's
kind of weird - that's kind of a weird
data source and yeah as far as we know
we are one of the only places that is
automatically ingesting and transcribing
talk radio 163 radio stations across the
country so this is the map of so on the
talk radio we've been ingesting and this
is one of our products called earshot
and it's a product for journalists to
surface the goal is that they can better
hear local voices so what people in
certain communities are talking about so
here's an example of what you might use
earshot for so let's say I want to know
what people in Boston are talking about
regarding donuts and not too
surprisingly we get a lot of results for
Dunkin Donuts and you can start to so
you could click the play button I hear
what people are calling in about about
Donuts
if that is what you are interested in
another thing is let's say you don't
know really what you're interested in
but you just want to get a sense of what
people are searching or started talking
about in Boston so this was taken this
screenshot was taken a few weeks ago
October 22nd and so you can see there is
like migrant Caravan there's also this
DNA test and Pocahontas and we can
probably see that that's prior result of
Elizabeth Warren releasing the results
of her DNA test and this is a pretty
Boston issue given that Elizabeth Warren
is the senator of Massachusetts and
continues to be alright so that I chose
another city
Atlanta Georgia mostly because I
personally don't know that much about
Atlanta Georgia so we also see Caravan
so that's sort of more of a national
news topic and we also see some new
names show up such as Troy Davis
so I also did not know who that was so I
looked it up and it turns out it was the
six year anniversary of a pretty
high-profile murder in the Georgia area
so we can start to see that we are now
getting more into local issues but if we
take a look at this list again we start
to see some sort of weird weird things
like Go Daddy I looked it up and I
personally didn't find anything about Go
Daddy in the news there might have been
something that I missed but my opinion I
think it's more likely that it was just
a commercial that aired on talk radio
maybe in a few radio stations in Georgia
and I got picked up by our algorithms
and said yeah GoDaddy is trending in
Atlanta so we can start to see that
duplicates in public radio isn't isn't
great we don't want a user to have to go
through multiples of the same thing and
here most of all the same content even
though it's on rate different radio
stations and it gets over accounted for
in topic detection as we just saw and
finally it's harder to hear local voices
if there's too much syndicated content
and our whole goal is to hear local
voices alright so we started to look for
a solution and the things that we hear
are our goals we wanted to increase our
duplicate detection accuracy obviously
but also we are one of the only places
as far as we know that is been looking
at talk radio so we wanted to we didn't
really have a good picture of what that
landscape even looked like so we wanted
to see can we visualize how much of talk
radio even is syndicated content and
also understand clusters of radio
stations so are there certain networks
that are out there with different
certain partnerships between radio
stations that we we have no idea about
all right so we learned of that about
this technology called audio
fingerprinting and the important part is
that you get an audio file and that
turns into a series of hashes and once
you have the hashes you can start
comparing them so you might be thinking
wait this makes no sense you are
transcribing radio data why not just
compare the words that's a pretty common
or more common thing that you might
think to do and the answer is that we we
are transcribing I'm sorry we are
detecting duplicates within the
transcripts but it's a few caveats to
that so transcription accuracy varies
with background noise of which
commercials have a good amount of or
like jingles in the background or sounds
in the background and also it's limited
to only English and not only just
English but a very certain kind of
probably like northeastern typical
accent so there are some places where we
weren't getting as many as much accuracy
as we would have liked and that godaddy
result is after our transcript duplicate
detection had been applied to it so we
were hoping that audio fingerprinting
might be oh it's a compliment what we
already had alright so I'm not going to
go too into this but basically if you
want to find fingerprints from an audio
file you would do some fancy FFT and
spectrogram stuff find some peaks in it
if you want to learn more about it I
suggest reading the Shazam white paper
so Shazam for those of you that might
not know is an app that you have on your
phone and you sort of hold it up as some
music is playing and your phone will
tell you what song that is so this is
the technology behind that so really the
important part is just that we get this
list of hashes and a twitch at what
position the hashes occurred in each
audio file that's all we need to know in
the context of this talk all right so
what existing tools are out there
there's Shazam but we needed to find
something that we could use so flex an
open-source library so there's this
awesome DejaVu library written in Python
and this
person who made it actually made it
because he had read the Shazam light
paper and thought I think I can do this
as well so I'm gonna walk through how
the deja vu algorithm works and this is
the library that we ended up adapting
but so I'm gonna go through how this one
works so that I can go into how we
changed it so let's say we have a
fingerprint of top 40 songs such as
these songs and for each one we have
this list of hashes so this is actually
a my sequel database of pop songs all
right so let's say you are at a
conference and you hear a beautiful
voice coming over the loudspeaker and
you have this wave of nostalgia and you
say I need to know what this song is so
you hold up your phone and the song goes
into your phone your phone fingerprints
it so now we have a hash for that as
well I'm sorry a series of hashes for
that and then it does this comparison so
this comparison isn't trivial it's a
pretty hard comparison because it's
unlikely that you held up your phone
right when the song started so it's not
like you can just compare the beginning
of each song you have to compare every
sequence with every other sequence in
your database so that's it's a little
tricky but your phone is able to do it
and it says this is toxic by Britney
Spears and you say well I'm glad I
figured that out alright so now I'm
going to talk about our problem because
we're not looking at Britney Spears
songs unfortunately we're looking at
talk radio which is great as well so
let's look at this pipeline and our
problem it looks looks more like this
where in the world is that but instead
of matching on just one song we actually
want to match on many songs so you can
think of a snippet of talk radio more as
a string of possible duplicate content
so you can imagine it's more like for
Britney songs played in a row possibly
with interruptions in the middle like
some local anchor
comes and chimes his voice and then they
go back to the national content and we
want to return each of the songs that
match not just the one that matched the
most so we don't want to say yep
that entire stream was toxic if it only
matched like 25% it's likely that
different parts matched different audio
content and so talk radio is really more
like a string of commercials followed by
some independent content and then maybe
puts play from other stations or jingles
from their own shows played throughout
the day so that's the first problem
second problem is that we need to know
what time these duplicates occurred
because we want to be able to say from 1
minute to 2 minutes in clip a that was
the same content as from 3 minutes to 4
minutes and quit B so don't double count
those words when you're doing your China
detection all right and then there's a
third problem and it's a really big one
and that is the volume of our data so we
have a hundred sixty-three radio
stations across 37 states ends up being
3.5 terabytes of audio ingested per
month per day we ingest 50,000 files so
that's a few minutes of audio per
station for 24 hours and then once we
start thing and printing it a typical
file has about 10,000 fingerprints so
and once again you're doing your
comparison not on a one-to-one basis but
but comparing sub sequences with sub
sequences so it's a lot of fingerprints
to compare so the question is how do you
scale it alright so I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you so this is our our radio ingest
pipeline before we did anything with
fingerprinting at all so we can think of
this whole duplicate detection process
and split it up into two parts so the
first part we will call fingerprinting
so the actual generation of the
fingerprint tables and the second part
will call matching so how do we scale a
fingerprinting and it turns out this
isn't too hard we already have I believe
something like 40 machines that are
doing our ingesting and transcription so
we just added this line and we say hey
why don't you fingerprint it as well and
we don't really know what will happen to
it yet but just store it in s3 and we'll
figure it out so that looks something
like this
where you have your audio the name of
your audio file you have some metadata
about how it was fingerprinted and then
you have your list of hashes and their
positions in the songs all right sorry
clips you're not songs anymore okay but
how do you scale duplicate detection and
this is harder because you can't it's
not just a simple map because everybody
needs to know about everybody else's
data so you can't avoid comparing
everybody with everybody else otherwise
you can't generate this nice map of talk
radio as a whole alright so we decided
we probably couldn't use my sequel
anymore and decided we should go with
spark so hold all the values in memory
with spark and see how see how it does
so the original code was not written in
a functional way so part of our
rejiggering was that we had to rethink
the process I'm only using map and
reduce functions so I'm going to go a
bit into that but not too into that so
if you really want to go into that I
have this notebook this is an observable
notebook I don't know if maybe I used it
before but they're really great for we
actually built this to the bugs and load
our code but I ended up fleshing it out
into a full-on tutorial if you're
interested in the actual algorithm
behind it so there are some animations
and parameters you can play with this is
in so observable uses JavaScript so it's
not the actual code which is in Python
and PI spark but it's a good for just
explaining and visualizing what what
this algorithm looks like all right so
let's walk through it so you start with
a list of fingerprint files so these
were output by this is output by our
fingerprint process and this is just a
list of paths through the files first
thing you want to do is download them so
that's our first map okay it's pretty
simple we can do that next we want to
group by hash value so everybody that
has the same hash value grouped together
next I want to calculate offsets this is
a little tricky to explain but basically
you want so see how you have this orange
content that's the same across both
clips you want to line them up so you
want you say like a G - G is 10 H - H is
10 and you want to calculate those
offsets all those tens and that's 12 and
everything else
and then you want to group by those
offsets and now you can start to see how
these duplicate content start to line up
and then you want to find the time range
so let's say you have needs these series
of hashes that match we do a low-pass
filter in order to figure out the actual
time range of that duplicate content and
finally group again by song name I'm
sorry clip name and so our output file
looks something like this where you have
name of the audio file and then followed
by a tuple of the audio file itself what
times and matched with and then the
other audio file that it matched with
and the times I didn't act with on the
other audio file and that's it so the
infrastructure so this was kind of neat
because we didn't have a spark
infrastructure at all so they told me to
go do it so that's what I did so we used
three technologies spark obviously um
ec2 and kubernetes so kubernetes we were
using for a lot of our orchestration
already so we thought hey wouldn't it be
cool if we had this on-demand spark
cluster kubernetes as well so I'm going
to walk through this that's me and so
let's say I want a spark cluster I run
my stuff on so I say hey kubernetes I
have this spark job and it needs 50 CPUs
can you help me out and kubernetes talks
to its autoscaler so this is something
that we have configured in kubernetes
that monitors the nodes that kubernetes
is orchestrating and it keeps track of
system processes so it can tell if a
node can have more work put on it or if
we need to get more from get more notes
from some higher source so kubernetes
asked the autoscaler hey do we have 50
CPUs lying around and the autoscaler
says no we're a non-profit but but I
know who to ask for more so I go - so
the autoscaler goes to Amazon ec2 where
we also have an auto scaling group
enabled and this auto scaling group
actually bids for spot instances
Amazon ec2 so this is Amazon's way of
auctioning off their extra resources so
we can make this pretty affordable also
so the downside of getting this cheap
price is that they can yank your spot
instance away when when they need to but
luckily SPARC is pretty good about being
interrupted so so it would turn out to
be a pretty good solution for us so
amazon bids on these instances and it
says hey give me seven machines with
eight cores it gives that to us and
spark says all right I can go do my work
now so it goes over there
it's chugging along this process right
now it takes about three hours each day
for us so eventually the spark child
finishes and the autoscaler says all
right notices that there are some
underutilized notes lying around so it
asks Amazon ec2 to relinquish them so
those are gone now and not eating up our
bill the autoscaler is happy there's no
jobs that require more CPU and there and
all the existing notes are being used to
a good capacity all right let's look at
this whole pipeline again and we see
that there's one super slow part of this
and that's me so replace me with a cron
job or kuben Rd the kubernetes cron job
and I can be here hanging out with all
of you instead all right so let's look
at some results this is a visualization
of radio stations in Madison Wisconsin
so there are four radio stations that
can be heard if you were to drive
through Madison and a line shows or a
given blue section shows content that
was duplicated in some and any other
radio station that we are ingesting so
this particular one shows for Monday
October 15th and just looking at this
you can see right away which stations
tend to air more unique content so for
instance an example wo RT has a lot of
white space where it's where that
content isn't found anywhere else in the
talk radio that we are ingesting and the
neat thing about this and you can
explore it like that bitly link I have
in the bottom is I did this for a week
data and you can tell how it changes per
day of the week so on weekends wo RT
actually has even less blue blue lines
and the other ones shift as well and
then if you scroll through just the
weekdays you can see wor T consistently
has that block of blue towards 10 P 1011
p.m. UTC so maybe during that time they
they take a break in there some
duplicated content but our contact out
in Madison Wisconsin said it turns out
wor T is very proud of their independent
nature and they would be very happy if
they ever saw this slide alright so this
one is it's an interesting one so this
is all the notes here are radio stations
and they are linked such as a force
directed graph and they are linked if
they have a certain threshold of
duplicate content between them so a
certain number of minutes of duplicate
content between them and otherwise they
have a repelling force and that's what
makes them spread out so I I made this
first active graph and then I thought I
needed some color so I colored them
completely independently of any
duplicate detection results and I was
sort of shocked to see this this very
clear block of red as well as this very
pure block of blue orange so red is
actually a public radio and that tends
to be morally and PR stations and blue
is what's classified as news / talk and
we found that to be more of the
conservative talk radio stations so you
can see this this gap between the two
and it was so the first time we were
seeing any of this map out and talk
radio and then on the outskirts you can
see there's one brown dot way to way to
the left and that is actually a college
radio station which doesn't seem to have
any duplicate contents with anybody else
around it and that's that made sense to
us and might make sense to you if you
have ever heard of a college radio
station hi yeah alright so we've been
running this for I checked my kubernetes
logs and
haven't edited the cron job for 38 days
so it's been chugging along and just
reporting out duplicates for us we're
pretty excited to dive into a few things
one is commercial detection so can we
detect commercials save the same
commercials that are airing across
different stations and then maybe we can
get a sense of who is funding these
stations are there are there patterns
there and also if we remove all that
syndicated content all that national
news can we train on different accents
from different parts of the country and
that could really go back and help out
transcript duplicate our transcript
transcription in general as well as
hopefully speech recognition as a whole
to not only be trained on a certain
accent alright so I guess I'm wrapping
up alright so relevant links um the
first link is a link from my a blog post
for my colleagues on how they made radio
searchable in the first place so this
doesn't have any audio fingerprinting
but it's a great read if you just want
to learn about the ingesting and
transcription process second there's the
DejaVu Python library which we couldn't
have done this without there is a blog
post on how to run your kubernetes jobs
as ec2 spot instances and lastly if you
if you're nostalgic a link to a good
song alright that's actually all I have
I guess I went I think I'm done yeah
let's see it thank you so much for
coming to my talk
have you thought about podcasts yes we
have thought about podcast so where we
are a research group out of MIT Media
Lab and not one of the other groups has
actually a podcast corpus so we are
going to try to apply our transcription
to the podcast to the podcasts that they
have as well yes so looking forward to
seeing what kind of things we get out of
that any other questions or else we can
break for up we got one here we go do
you have an understanding of your false
positive rate yeah so that's the hard
part so that's something that we just
started going into for the most part if
it finds the false positive rate at
least but we have haven't been able to
tell just from listening has been very
low if it is a false positive then it
tends to be like they do sound very
similar I guess maybe the opening and
closing of a show it has like the same
jingle is around it but so yeah that's
part of the reason why we made that
notebook so we could adjust the
parameters and see how things change but
yeah that's a hard problem most of us
involves listening to a lot of audio but
yes so working on that and what we're
really most interested in is the not
false positive but what we're missing so
and we think that is quite a bit but so
starting to compare that to our
transcript duplicate detection and
seeing what that finds versus what our
audio fingerprinting finds and trying to
understand how they can complement each
other or something we're actively
working on final questions Oh someone in
the back nope
here we go
great talk I have a question about how
you feed the data to your model or
you've you mentioned something about
converting audio to fft directly have
you considered like speech to text
translation and then generating in
codings on top yeah so we're sort of
doing both so we were already doing that
speech to text since I'm sorry if I'm
misunderstanding your question but we're
already doing that speech to text
translation but the speech to text is
susceptible to a lot of outside factors
so we were hoping to have this around as
well to complement it does that answer
your question yeah and how does it how
does the performance for the two compare
yeah that's something we were just
looking at this week actually they seem
to find different things which is
interesting also some of the same things
but it seems like the overlap for
different things is actually higher so
we're still looking into that and it
does seem like every time both find
something it is something so we are
probably under counting all that
duplicate content and so yeah we haven't
really combined the two yet but that's
something we would like to do soon
[Music]